[Music]
clement is with us clement is in tampa
florida hi clement how are you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
hey i just want to say it's an honor to
talk to you guys about today um i was
approached by
a lawyer from canada uh about a person
with the same last name i have who
deceased a while back roughly nine years
ago
and uh they approached me saying that
there's there's some money left behind
an insurance policy after he died
uh roughly 13 million dollars and um
they approached me saying that hey we
wanted to tap into that and you can be a
beneficiary one thing we ask is that we
give ten percent to
your local charity or a church of your
choosing and then we would split the
remainder 50 50. i want to know if um if
this is a common thing or not or if i'm
getting scammed and you're getting a
question
yeah it's a scam
oh
no there's no such thing
as an insurance policy where a lawyer
gets 50 of it for finding you
not in not even in canada
[Laughter]
i don't know why that got me so good i'm
sorry not american yes there's just no
such thing clement i mean that's just
that's complete bogus crap
the person of the same name you don't
even know a relative you don't even know
never even heard of them you had no idea
you knew anybody in canada
you yeah you don't
you know
and so and the next thing is they're
going to want some money from you up
front to get this all settled and
figured out yeah because you've got to
pay the upfront fees to get the
documentation done or some crap and
that's where they scam you
but there's not a you know
sorry i i hate to burst your bubble but
uh there's a nigerian prince also that
wants some help getting his money out if
you haven't heard that one it's very
similar
um yeah that that's there's just not a
there's no such product out there
there's no
process in the legal system and probate
no lawyers of any kind that do probate
law
take half
for distributing an inheritance that
they had nothing to do with they just
don't do it there's no such thing
nor do they nor they do they demand what
you do with the money like give ten
percent of it today that's what i always
get that the scammer with a heart oh we
want you to give some of the two well
that's to give the thing credibility
right
yeah possibly yeah he didn't say he was
going to get half of it he said i i
would be liable to paying him half after
i received the full
amount
yeah it's it's a straight up this is a
standard scam procedure
and um you're going to have to put the
money up somewhere and at some point
before you get money and that's when
they're going to take you uh they're
going to it's
you know
so no
as a matter of fact if i were you i
would report this to the fbi
huh
okay because i'm pretty sure this is
going on quite a bit and you know this
is this thing's coming
waves but i'm sorry i wish you were
getting half of 13 million dollars i
wish that for you
out of the blue from nowhere but i can
there's nothing about this that doesn't
smell like a scam i would waste no time
on it and for sure don't give them any
of your banking information don't give
them any card information don't give
them any
any further information on you that they
can use to trap you into some kind of
corner later because this is what
they're after here
and uh and they're going gonna be
persistent
and they're gonna make fun of you and do
all kinds of things and what you need to
do is just get away from them as fast as
you can this is a bad deal here
yeah i just don't know what to say
i mean wow
that's pretty bold
well they do it
there was one i'm trying to remember how
they did it it was the spanish lottery
and it came out of canada too and it was
a standard scam and i don't remember the
process on it it was called the spanish
lottery and they would call you up and
say you won the spanish lottery and i'm
like i didn't know it was in it right
and so yeah buy a ticket but then you
had to you had to post the money
in order to prove that it was you and
then they would switch it around and
then by the time they switch it around
your part never came but they took the
part that you put in and it's it's a it
was a
process i can't remember the details of
how it rolls out but it's very very
interesting